follow the rhetoric about non-doms and  unpaid tax if your party were in power  do you think you could ever bridge the  gap between the richest and the poorest  what's your name  surely surely yeah it's a great question  shirley and let me answer it directly  yes there's this rule that shirley's  referring to called the non-dom rule now  some of you may know about it some of  you may not but basically it means you  can live here work here be permanently  settled here but not pay taxes here it's  been in place believe it or not for 200  years that's 40 prime ministers i'm  going to get rid of it i'm going to get  rid of it because i believe in a country  where there's run one rule for all not  one rule for the rich and powerful and  another rule for everybody else now  david cameron wants to defend that rule  now i think he's wrong about that i  think we've got to tackle tax avoidance  wherever we find it and make people at  the top live up to their  responsibilities